The meaning that sustains you in life and responsibility,
which is not a case that's made very effectively but needs to be made.
Because most of the meaning that people experience in their lives that's
worthwhile is a consequence of,
of adopting voluntary responsibility.
How do you mean?
Well,
you think about the people you admire,
her,
the reason that you get out of bed on a hard day,
it's because you have worthwhile things to do that you think are necessary and
important.
And those usually involve at minimum taking care of yourself.
But if you're,
if you're,
if you're developed in a reasonable manner,
then you have a family to take care of and you have a community to set,
right?
And you have things that need to be done to reduce the amount of unnecessary
suffering in the world and to constrain the amount of malevolence that you
manifest or that you encounter and you need that sort of meaning to offset the
fact that life is difficult.
The,
the title of your book is at 12 rules for life,
an antidote to cows and I come to chaos laser.
But the 12 rules as you read them,
standup state,
just shoulders back,
don't get children,
do anything that makes you dislike them at set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world app.
Get kind of,
they sound like common sense,
common sense.
But if people forget why common sense is common,
you know,
it's common for a reason or and and in,
in then if those common sense dictums are challenged,
people don't necessarily know how to defend them because they're,
they seem self evident.
So partly what I've done in the book is to take things that people know,
um,
and purposefully so,
and to outline why they're true and conceptually and philosophically,
but also why they're necessary to apply practically.
And to do both of those at the same time cause abstract conceptions aren't much
use unless you can nail them down to something that's practically implementable.
And so I made sure I bridged the gap between those,
those,
what extremes in the book.
What,
what do you think makes you so controversial?
Well,
I think that's a,
that's a good question.
I mean many things are controversial in today's politically polarized climate.
And everything gets politicized.
I am controversial.
I became embroiled in controversy in part because of,
uh,
because I'm no friend of the collectivist left wing.
And I've made that very clear and I objected to some legislation in Canada that
was passed that compelled speech in a manner that had never been,
never been attempted in any system that utilizes English common law and which I
thought and still believe it was an absolutely appalling piece of legislation.
But to push it simply for our listeners,
that's me patronizing the listeners.
But I mean,
you talk about these things at length,
it has to do,
no,
you tell me what it has to do with,
well,
it has to do as far as I'm concerned with the attempts by a coterie of
relatively radical left wing collectivist to establish linguistic dominance in
certain conceptual spheres.
So for example,
we have the idea that gender expression and gender identity are purely socially
constructed and also,
um,
independent of biology.
That's basically be written into the legal fabric in Canada now.
And that's preposterous.
It's factually incorrect,
overwhelmingly factually incorrect.
And it's purely ideological stance.
But people do w trans as they say,
and he put a Stencil,
really are female do become male and vice versa.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean that they very independently things can be linked in
still,
I'm still variation.
Well the overwhelming majority of people who are biologically male identify as
male.
It's more than 99.9% and the overwhelming majority of people who are
biologically female identify as female and are heterosexual.
And so the idea that those things are independent is insane.
They're not even close to independent.
That doesn't mean there aren't,
there aren't exceptions.
And when you're crafting laws,
especially when it's associated with scientific facts,
you have to get your terminology right.
The claim of the social constructionists is that all of these areas,
uh,
biological sex,
gender expression,
gender identity,
um,
so sexual preference vary independently and it's all a consequence of
socialization.
That's wrong.
It's wrong at every single level of analysis.
And it's important.
Well,
there are biological influences play a major role on people obviously.
And not only that,
as your societies become more egalitarian,
and this has been demonstrated clearly in the Scandinavian countries,
as societies become more egalitarian in their social policies,
the differences between men and women get bigger,
not smaller.
How well,
because it turns out that if you flatten out the socio cultural structure,
which is one of the things that make men and women the same as it turns out the
biological differences maximize.
So the biggest differences in personality and interest,
which partly determines occupational choice.
For example,
the biggest differences are in the Scandinavian countries and they've grown.
Has the Scandinavian countries,
Scandinavian countries have become more egalitarian.
And how does that manifest?
What manifests itself and occupational choice for example,
but and but also in in personality.
How do you mean in occupation or choice?
I mean there are fewer women in the stem studies as societies in the stem
fields,
science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics.
As societies become more egalitarian,
fewer women go into the stem fields,
not more.
And it looks like it's a consequence of their free choice.
Partly because the personality differences between men and women,
between men and women grow as societies become more equal.
And so do the differences in their interest.
It's because men and women are actually biologically different to some degree.
Now,
you know,
men and women are quite the,
quite similar.
So for example,
if you look at a trait like aggression,
if you pick a random man and a random woman out of the population and you had to
lay a bet on who was more aggressive,
if you bet on the woman,
you'd be right 40% of the time,
which an yes.
And so that's quite an overlap,
right?
But then if you go out to the extremes and if you had to pick the one in 100
most aggressive person,
it would almost always be male.
And that's why so many men are in prison.
So it's 10 to one males to female in prison.
Now.
And that's partly because you can have very much similarity in population
overlap in the middle,
but quite a lot of difference at the extremes.
You.
It was alleged that you made very controversial remarks following the m Harvard
events in Toronto where a man who's at,
I presume we'll do life killed,
I think it was 10 people and drove insurable and wanted to do more and arising
from that,
it was implied that somehow that this had to do with the fact that he couldn't
have sex with a woman.
Well,
you said it was alleged that I make controversial comments.
That's exactly right.
You got the terminology right there.
What I pointed out was that social in enforcement of monogamous norms is one way
that societies around the world,
male aggression at bay,
and that's an absolutely solid finding from a hundred years of anthropology,
one that's often cited by people on the left.
So what happened in the New York Times article that you're referring to was that
that was taken radically out of context and their old reporter knew that
perfectly well.
She was very intelligent young woman.
She knew exactly what she was doing when she did that,
and to make the case that monogamous social norms,
which are pretty much universal around the world,
by the way,
even though people have some tendency towards multiple partners,
the reason that monogamous social norms emerge is partly to keep male aggression
under control.
That's not controversial.
Anybody who knows the anthropological psychological literature understands it's,
that's the purpose of it.
Well,
there's a variety of purposes,
but that's definitely one.
Polygamous societies are way more violent,
not a little bit more violent,
way more violent.
Yeah,
so that's part of the purpose.
There's a variety of purposes.
You want people to have longterm stable partners because that's probably better
for men and women in general.
Now the,
well,
yes,
that would be good if,
if it,
if it can be managed in how,
I think on many situations that's a luxury.
I mean,
people have hard lives,
have had hard lives throughout history,
and they've made decisions for,
for very basic economic reasons.
If,
if your relationship is also characterized by love,
great.
But you know,
life is very difficult for people and has been for a very long period of time.
The primary reason that monogamy is enforced socially is for children as far as
I can tell,
because of course obviously children are dependent for very long periods of time
and we know even in western societies,
which are relatively prosperous,
people who serve as single parents tend to plummet down the economic hierarchy
because it's very,
very difficult to have a fulltime productive job and take care of children by
yourself.
And we also know the literature on child development indicates w beyond the
shadow of the doubt,
the two parent families are far more effective with regards to the outcome of
children than single parent families,
which is an imagine many people we'd be ringing in to say not to,
not to handle,
they want.
There's a literature developed on this that's developed over decades that
indicates this extraordinarily clearly.
So fatherlessness for example,
is a very potent predictor of negative outcomes among children.
That doesn't mean that every person who's a single parent is doing a bad job.
Those are not the same claims.